thank you very much well actually in a
change to the advertised program i'm
actually going to talk about whether
government is sustainable so i think it
is kind of a more entertaining topic but
i will start by giving you some
background as to why i'm going to talk
about where the government is
sustainable not which is that for the
past 20 years or so I've been tackling
that question in one way shape or form
and i started in 1991 my undergraduate
thesis on the cost of carbon control and
then at that time i was really quite
concerned about the environment and you
know I i still feel concerned about the
environment but my concern was was was
heightened by the time that we were
living in 91 it was the year before the
Rio convention when there was a lot of
discussion about the dangers of our
actions towards the environment the
green parties were becoming more and
more powerful in Europe and I thought
you know this is the area to get into it
didn't I wouldn't pass my mind that the
girls who were involved in environmental
concerns were also kind of hot but you
know that day I I can see that this was
this was the wave of the future and so I
got very very involved in it and
numerous papers and so on and over the
course of past 20 years have tried to
develop some arguments about how we
should think about climate change energy
production our impacts on the
environment more generally and so this
is a PowerPoint presentation which are
produced with that in mind to try and
talk about and of what the underlying
institutions are that might bring us to
a better place with regard to protecting
the environment so I'm going to quickly
talk about what the meaning of
sustainable about this is a concept that
is now 120 years old and still is
bandied around quite a lot increasingly
of course now that we have a government
in power here in
when in Britain both of which are kind
of in favor of Environmental Protection
in whatever that might mean I'm going to
talk about the development of growth
economic growth and the impact on human
welfare and we'll talk about this idea
of the Kuznets curve I'll explain that
and then I will talk about some examples
of unsustainable development it's useful
to contextualize the idea of sustainable
development by seeing examples of where
it's gone wrong so here we go well
sustainable development was defined in
the brundtland reporters the world
Commission on environment development in
1997 as development that meets the needs
of the present generation without
compromising the ability of future
generations to meet their needs I mean
what can you say it difficult difficult
to disagree with that place so the
problem is actually operationalizing it
and I came to the conclusion that we can
we can agree with the definition in
general but we should look at how in
fact we might bring it about through
seeing it is a process rather than as an
outcome for the most part the proponents
of sustainable development say that you
know we've got this defined outcome
preventing global warming killing the
humanity in 20 100 or more narrowly
trying to reduce some impact on a
specific species in a particular place
well I think we have to look at more how
people engage in economic activities and
what what rules you can put in place
that incentivize those economic action
it took to be beneficial mutually
beneficial without doing as much harm to
the environment so I'm that took me to
look at the role of property rights I
did some work looking at the the issue
of desertification which was a very
popular idea in the 1970s and there was
at the actually the first UN Convention
on environment and development in 1972
it was one of the big things
desertification and someone said that
the Sahara
expanding northwards and was going to
destroy the North Africa turns out that
it's not really expanding northwards or
southwards but there is a problem with
land degradation and the problem of land
degradation results from the fact that
people don't have the right incentives
to use their land well and so they
degrade it so the question is well why
is land in some places used well and not
in others and it turns out that property
rights of the key if you define property
rights well enable people to own an
exchange property then they have
incentives to use that property in ways
that benefits them so they will conserve
so they will invest in improving that
land rather than harming it and it also
enables people to your property as
collateral from loans for loans so you
can get a lower cost loan which enables
you to invest in a business proposition
which may or may not lead to
improvements in productivity which leads
to economic growth the other thing
that's really important is the root of
law in countries that have the root of
law people are able to engage in
business transactions knowing that
they're not going to have their their
property their their the things that
they produce arbitrary exploit
expropriated by government in places
without the rule of law in places where
governments can simply step in willy
nilly arbitrarily that then people are
less willing to invest in business
activities because they're concerned
about that the possibility that there
the products will be stolen from them so
so we can see examples of entrepreneurs
being motivated by a desire to improve
their lot developing technologies that
benefit all of us so I'll give them
three examples here the transistor which
is invented by bell labs which replaced
the cumbersome inefficient valves
enabling mass production of electronic
high-tech electronic products I thought
these examples were kind of useful in a
giving a talk in California where I'm
many of these things were invented the
integrated circuit into invented by Jack
Kilby at texas instruments okay Texas
there too and enabled mass production of
personal computers are lenient the
automation of many tasks no knots fiber
optic cable Delap what developed by
Corning revolutionized high-speed
telecoms enabling the development of the
internet so why do I give these three
examples well because these are these
are green technologies they weren't
developed as green technologies though
and this is important you know no one
gets que no one no government official
no Barack Obama started a program in the
in the 1920s AR we've got to develop
some green technologies let's let's
let's invest in green jobs and yeah ok
I'm investing the transistor the
integrated circuit and low loss
fiber-optic cable we add that that's
going to be a certain that this is not
how innovation takes place innovation it
occurs I often through all sorts of
mechanisms which we which which rely on
on tacit knowledge of the local
circumstances it relies on insights
occurring that have nothing to do with
whither with a central directed program
but because of these three technologies
which were invented independently and
without a few towards developing some
kind of low carb and green technology we
are able to move ideas in the form of
and instantiations of ideas music data
and so on across millions of miles and
at very high speeds and low cost without
burning nearly as much fossil fuels as
we would have done previously so they
are currently that they aren't they are
green technologies may be the ultimate
green technology and more generally the
incentives to innovate and develop new
technologies for the benefit of for the
profit basically leads to all sorts of
of innovations that are that are high
benefit we got Harry teasley sitting in
the audience so you make may or may not
know the expression coals to Newcastle
but so so so when harry's at coca-cola
and he did a lot to a lightweight the
cans that coke Cola produced and I'm
sure he's talked to you about it but
drink cans now contain much less than
half the metal that they contained in
the 1970s as a result of innovations
that sought to improve profits that it
was simply done to reduce the amount of
material going into the can and the cost
of transporting the cans from place to
place cars are now cheaper lighter safer
and faster and less polluting than they
were 10 or 20 years ago I'm look at
these two examples of light weighting
also to reflect on the work that Lynne
scarlet did when she was a reason
foundation I mean I think she did an
enormous amount to communicate the
importance of allowing innovation to
take place in a decentralized private
environment because that led to these
sorts of light weighting innovations
that are so beneficial for society and I
think that's the kind of program that we
want to continue where that reason there
are other other innovations that have
been enormously important in terms of
increasing productivity and reducing
costs pesticides fertilizers and so on
have massively increased agricultural
productivity and these have led to
economic growth and basically the
improvements in factor productivity and
the development of goods that better
Goods at lower costs that people want to
buy results in the surplus that we and
and continued generation of capital that
we call economic growth so we can see
that before
widespread private property and the rule
of law the world was a poor place it was
poor this Angus Madison put together
this data so until about 1500 we're
talking about one hundred dollars per
capita per year GDP and it was it what
you know Hobbes his description of it
nasty brutish and so on was was was true
and short people lived over you know
people people didn't live threescore
years and ten and then from 1500 or
words in Europe especially things
started to get better as security of
property was improved and then after
1800 literally exploded so you've had
this this this just vapid expansion of
economic activity as the the idea of
private property has spread more widely
around the world and people have been
able to engage in economic more
economically productive activities and
you see from 1820 till today the
proportion of people living on a dollar
a day in the world has has fallen
dramatic i'm sure i can update this 22
in the last five years with with new
data but it carries on falling for the
most part and you can see the poverty
although it rose because population rose
dramatically over that period as well
it's been falling for about the past 30
years now and i think also significantly
a more rapid economic growth leads to
more rapid ECMO rapid reduction in
poverty there are those who claim that
you know there is there this there's
homes from economic growth it is somehow
some people are made more poor by pi can
written no it's the opposite if you grow
faster the the number of people who come
out of poverty falls faster and here you
have a graph showing life expectancy at
birth and and gni per to place
nationally in power come
now this I think fairly clearly shows
that it's better to be wealthy it's
better cooler so you do want to have
those institutions that enable you to
generate wealth and this is one of the
reasons why it's better to be wealthy
because if you're wealthy then you have
access to clean drinking water and it's
the dirty drinking water which is a
particularly heinous threat to health
throughout the world but nutrition is
also important and here you've seen this
is the consequence of those improvements
in agricultural technology crops
fertilizer pesticide and so on rapidly
rising access to nutrition throughout
the world even in Africa has seen
although it's still it's not it's
benefited less than than any other area
and you've seen in previous of
environmental this is actually an
autograph but you can see how many of
the worst pollutants have fallen
dramatically what one of the interesting
things is how they fell considerably in
the 1960s oh this is before the creation
of the Environmental Protection Agency a
lot of this is is you know driven by a
simply improvements in efficiency some
is driven by by regulations I'm not
going to say that regulations are all
bad but but but but a lot of it was
improved driven by improvements in
efficiency and so this led to some words
suggesting that there was an
environmental Kuznets curve so simon
kuznets wrote wrote about other things
but there was some a bunch of analysts
showed that in the initial stages of
economic development typically you have
relatively low levels of economic growth
but low levels of environmental impact
as you as growth as economic output
increases so environmental impact
increases but then you come to a turning
point and after that turning point I
growth increases in the environment
improves so and this is work by Bruce
yandel who presented at a Resource Bank
sorry reason we came last year he didn't
get this work which i think is very
interesting he showed that these are the
levels of which you get the
environmental because its curve turning
point for different chemicals of
different different pollutants and so
you see that the ones which are
eliminated first or which which which
declined first are nitrates in water and
and other waterborne bacteria and and so
for example total coliform is the third
one from the bottom that that begins to
decline at about five thousand dollars
per capita so that's where you see the
economic growth having significant
benefits in terms of reducing water
pollution as you go higher up the the
turning point goes higher but
interestingly at the top you have carbon
dioxide and there's some suggestion then
that you have a turning point for carbon
dioxide production at somewhere between
37 and 57,000 US dollars per capita now
if that's true then the solution to
global warming if calm dive site is is
there is a significant problem and
causes global warming is is rapid
economic growth because will then be
able to afford to reduce carbon dioxide
emissions or maybe do other technologies
that enable us to do so more effectively
and of course you don't have to have the
same levels of wealth in every country
to adopt the technology so here we've
got the changes so I'll get back to the
first slide this is electricity
consumption in 1971 against wealth so
electricity consumption on the on the
vertical axis and wealth on the
zontal axis and you can see I'm sorry
these I should have a hands wrestling
type slide with sort of wonderful
bubbles growing out but in no time so so
you can see relatively low levels of
electricity consumption at all levels of
wealth but obviously wealthier people
have more access to electricity as time
goes on you can see electricity
consumption increasing firm for many in
many countries but even at the
relatively low levels of wealth and you
can see some of these so the right of
the left hand side you can see
relatively less wealthy people having
increasing amounts of electricity and
but of course you know that's not to say
that you don't want to have more wealth
because that you get more interesting
consumption and that's that's that's
that's a good thing you can have air
conditioning you can have heating you
can prevent a lots of nasty things from
happening and live much happier
healthier lives and one of the
consequences of increasing electricity
consumption is to reduce the burning of
coal and other things to produce nasty
indoor pollution so here's a graph of
the type of types of energy consumed by
people in homes in China and you can see
that and until the early 1980s coal was
the dominant source of of heating for
the home in China I mean dramatically so
and over time that's gradually been
replaced by electricity sokol is that is
is in is in pale blue and electricity is
the is there is the marine color above
that so the anchor increasing access to
electricity has had a huge impact on
what fuels people can seem at home and
this has impacts for particulate
pollution so here you have particulate
pollution in india and china between
1990 and 2002
see a fairly substantial decline minutes
continued declining for the most part
and that's in large measure in both
cases as a result of increasing access
to alternative forms of energy
especially electricity and that's been
enabled by the no-cost transfer of
technologies which were developed in
rich countries and the same is true in
many respects for improvements in child
mortality rates in poorer countries over
a period of 40 years you have dramatic
declines in child mortality rates as
vaccines and other technologies or
rehydration therapy is transferring the
West took to wealthy countries but a
combination of wealth and technology
transfer has also had substantial
impacts on one of the problems that
supposedly related to climate change so
here you have deaths from your death
rates from extreme weather events Oh
from 19 for the 1920s until the last
decade and you can see that as wealth
has risen on the on the red the red line
Beth's death rates from from
weather-related natural disasters has
fallen precipitously ms just tiny barely
measurable compared to the situation 100
years ago so this this this leads to a
sort of a revised environmental
Christmas cut so what what's being
explained here is that actually you have
problems when wealth is low but also
when you don't have access to
technologies as access to technology
improves then the the impact on the
environment improves more quickly but I
also want to give you some examples of
unsustainable development if I've got
some time so here's I took a trip in
2002 to from Delhi to a grass or growers
is where the Taj Mahal is and to go
there we went past this at the border
between Delhi and utter pradesh we went
past a queue of trucks that i think must
have been two or three miles long
I stopped at the end of the when we when
we stopped at the end of the queue to
transition into two pradesh i turned to
the driver and said what are we one of
these trucks doing this looks like a
sustainable transport they're not
they're not moving so that's that's
experiences then and and anything I
silly Britt and pointed out that that
there was a little kiosk nearby where
the truck drivers were getting a what's
called a chit then they were paying
their 50 rupees to get there chit and
then they could then they could pass
through but that process that takes time
we've got bureaucrats involved in it and
so they state that so the trucks just
sit there for hours some of these trucks
work we're transporting perishable goods
now I don't not many of them
refrigerated so this this is that this
is a wonderful contributor to which is a
major major problem throughout the
developing world especially which is the
how food just wastes between the farmer
and the and the consumer this is a
classic reason for it it is an example
of on sustainable development though so
from the 30s onwards the Soviets
attempted to increase output basically
by increasing inputs I mean so we all
know that if you put more into a sausage
machine you'll get more sausages out and
that was the basic premise of Soviet
productivity and so you did get a rise
in output to some extent but the problem
is that they didn't really they didn't
have the right signals to drive
efficiency improvements they they would
use Sears catalogues to identify what
prices were and and they and they and
they and they what they would you know
they would they would steal technologies
from the West or even even occasionally
by them the Fiat 25 i think it was was
well it became the dominant car in
in the entire Soviet Union but the
trouble is that in attempting to sort of
enforce this system they they they had
to instigate the most horrendous
political controls and at the end of the
day they also destroyed the environment
so in the area around the aral sea there
though several rivers going into the LLC
and these were diverted for the
production of cotton and by so doing
they caused real desert a vacation and
this is an example of unsustainable
development in India this little object
is what's called a gas regulator it it
you have to install it on your little
little natural gas canister in order to
enable gas to go into your cooker and at
least until recently the Delhi
government had a monopoly on these on
the supply of these regulators and you
would have to pay the equivalent of
sixty US dollars to buy this this
regulation that's actually that's
actually a regulator made in China that
you can buy for about 50 cents so the
Delhi government was taking his message
massive amount of money as a result a
large proportion of people in Delhi was
still in ten years ago burning wood and
done especially wood I'm good was I was
it was a dominant source of energy on
the in the peripheral area of Delhi
central delhi people had an ax tricity
that gas is on foot on the periphery
they were burning a lot of wood and it
was causing contributing to a major
amount of pollution and this ago these
photos from from these are just outside
the Taj Mahal in Agra which a village
that really would be recognizable to to
people who are experts on on medieval
European history I think the consequence
of this is that people burn every
someone seventy percent of the Indian
population still gets the majority of
its heat from burning wood wooden were
done with horrible consequences so
here's the
a graph of air put a figure of air
pollution impacts around the world one
at the bottom you can see outdoor air
pollution I concluded that for
comparison about that estimated these
are World Health Organization figures
and I don't trust the outdoor ethical
figures very very much because I know
what they're based upon but the indoor
figures i think it probably not bad and
they tell a really depressing story
acute low respiratory infections and
chronic obstructive pulmonary disorder
account for about one half million
deaths a year and if you think of it in
terms of life years lost it's much worse
because of the the fact that so many of
these are children and women were
relatively young women who live in
indoors and open our cooking the meal
indoors and getting subjected to this
noxious pollution so unser state less is
unsustainable development for sure so
the lessons are don't try to plan
centrally I think that that's pretty
clear enable private ownership enable
people to trade freely both locally and
internationally and prohibit arbitrary
discretionary actions of government
officials now I think that we now need
to think about applying these rules back
here in the United States and so one of
the things we're going to do a reason
foundation is develop a more ambitious
program on environmental issues
especially focusing on what the real
benefits of what the real measures are
that will lead to beneficial
environmental actions domestically and
question some of the devious
interventions which are being rolled out
now for example restrictions on all
sorts of technologies that are hugely
beneficial with their agricultural
technologies or indeed electricity
generating technologies thank you very
much